e hoje eu preciso imprimir a ficar do
fortnite na minha nova impressora 3D ou
imprimir peça por peça em alta resolução
para ficar a melhor secar possível e em
tamanho real assistir o vídeo até o
tempo só para vocês verem como é que
ficou esta secar e já está bem Deixei
muito like aqui nesse vídeo porque esse
vídeo que sem dúvida elas recebeu mais
trabalho a fazer Ok quando composta por
aí pessoal e pega isso aqui esse Sininho
aqui ó milagre o Sininho hocks Magno
Sininho Olha lá pessoal já estamos aqui
no primeiro a ficar em tamanho real é
preciso muitas peças e como vocês podem
ver eu tenho aqui uma pasta tem
a equipa a nossa secar Como podem ver
tem aqui pega de mão tem aqui a parte de
vocês encostou ao ombro tem aqui assim
as partes do mês peças principais tem
aqui a parte onde vai levar o gatilho
inclusive o gatinho deve estar alguns
por aqui exatamente está aqui o nosso
gatilho aqui em cima temos aquele Aquilo
é que fica por cima para vocês colocarem
uns leis as coisas assim é bem pessoal
está aqui a arma toda está bonitinha
pronta para imprimir Outro ponto O
pimento que não vou imprimir agora as
peças né porque senão ia levar essa tal
semana que eu já imprimi tudo prontinho
eu tive que estudar bem coloquei esse
configurações bem portanto eu já tenho
tudo impresso só para vocês terem uma
ideia eu vou agora dar por perto por fim
que é basicamente dizer ao programa que
eu quero imprimir assim OK eu iria
precisar de 80 ou está aqui 89 horas e
trinta e dois minutos ele vem mais tempo
bem mais ou menos uma semana imprimir
porque eu imprimi peça por peça para não
ser muito arriscado porque sempre me
tudo se dá erro uma peça vai dar aqui em
todas e vai estragar tudo então tive que
imprimir com muita calma
E aí
Oi e essa é Nossa secar pessoal está
aqui mais ou menos montada com você e
claro que não tenho aqui as peças todas
ainda falta eu tentei montar aqui com a
cola muito podre só para ter uma noção
de como é que ia ficar com podem ver
aqui ficou com outras cores Porque eu
tive que usar outro filamento porque o
filamento amarela acabou essa é a nossa
ai ai
Ah tá incrível né vai ficar mente assim
que tá pessoal e coloquei aqui este post
que tal fugir só para ter uma noção de
como é que ela ia ficar Ok mas aqui vou
ter que colar isso tudo muito bem que é
Para não saber destes riscos esse
sobrinhas não vão existir isso vai ficar
perfeitamente junto vou pintar com a cor
original da secar vou fazer os detalhes
estudos se ajudar uma lixa dela também
meu isso vai ficar incrível mas eu vou
fazer com calma pessoal o meu objetivo é
que ela fique mesmo igual a do fortnite
igual igual igual igual pintura detalhes
tudo vai se divertir vai lá e
E aí
e bora lá pessoal teu aqui na edição do
vídeo para comentar por cima para vocês
perceberem melhor eu escolhi duas colas
epóxi Escolhi um acoplast para ajudar a
juntar as peças eu mais para frente
explico é um recipiente para colocar a
Cola e um pincel para ajudar a espalhar
a cola pela peça e eu escolhi esta cola
de epóxi de dois componentes porque ela
é muito boa muito resistente Como podem
ver aí pela imagem o tubo tem duas
escolas e essas colas quando se misturam
fica uma cola muito mas muito forte e
uma coisa muito boa nela é que ela não
estraga o material eu imprimi a secar em
pele a que é um material que até um
pouco sensível quando estamos a falar de
colas E sprays então vocês tem que ter
muito cuidado ao material que usam
porque senão podem estragar a peça ou
seja em vez de colar eu podia
simplesmente só derreter o plástico e eu
não quero isso ok portanto Esta é uma
das melhores escolas que podem usar Se
tentar em casa escolheu sempre Cola
epóxi de dois componentes ok pessoal
aqui
a mínima ideia do que estava a fazer eu
simplesmente usei um pano para retirar o
excesso de cola que saía das peças eu
não sabia existir resultar Estava a
fazer errado ou não mas Pelos vistos
funciona por isso se fizer em casa e Se
tiverem assim restos de cola limpa em
com um pano rápido porque a cola sai
facilmente meu só não deixem secar a
cola porque se não é que ele vai ter
quase um pedaço de plástico Extra depois
vocês tem que arrancar e vai ser muito
difícil Então tirem a cola toda antes
que seque ok
Ah que bom pessoal Pelos vistos esta
secar vai demorar mais tempo do que eu
pensava porque esta Cola precisa de 24
horas para secar eu vou ter que esperar
esta primeira vez que me te Cola vou ter
que aplicar mais uma vez depois vou ter
que esperar pela pintura pela segunda
mão de pintura Isso significa que só
daqui a mais ou menos mais 4 ou 5 dias é
que eu vou ter a secar pronta mas o que
é bom aqui no YouTube é que vocês não
vão dar pelo tempo passar então até
amanhã e
E aí olha aí Dark frame a fazer bosta eu
aqui tentei colar os acessórios por cima
já mas eu esqueci-me que estas peças são
de outra cor portanto não vale a pena eu
colocar essa Peça já a mais-valia
separar e pintar que foi o que eu fiz a
seguir então eu aqui só desperdice a
cola Foi um erro e depois percebi e tive
que arrancar tudo então já sabem pessoal
se fizerem esta secar em casa não colem
as peças Ok Eita Agora complicou pessoal
eu vou utilizar este arco A plástico
para madeira para tapar todas estas
fissuras Karma tem porque dá para ver a
distância que isso foi para o lado tá
feio tem muitas imperfeições Então vamos
colocar assim um pouquinho de acoplado
eu aqui estava improvisar Ok pode haver
outras formas melhores vocês podem
comentar aí embaixo outras formas de
fazer isto é só foi mais prática e a que
eu tinha em casa para mais sei lá mais
improvisada que eu encontrei eu até
utilizei aqui a espátula para tentar
empurrar o acoplast mesmo lá para dentro
utilizei o pênis esfreguei depois aqui
vi que não
e também então acho que ainda coloquei
mais por cima preencher tudo mas mas pa
Tá revoltada a funcionar é o que
interessa a produção aqui
esfrega-esfrega isso tudo tá isso com
paciência com jeitinho com amor a nossa
ficar tem que sair com amor improvisada
ou não resultou haha ok pessoal o pior
colocar em um acoplada que vocês têm que
estar outra vez tudo de novo para tirar
todas as imperfeições com acoplast deu a
Açúcar eu já não dá conta de lixar é
muito podre e
e eu não sei se consegue alguém com esta
máscara mas está na hora do pintura e
vão pessoal relativamente as tintas
primeiro eu vou usar estes Pera aí que é
um primer Ok o Primer serve para vocês
darem aquela primeira camada para
retirarem o relevo que a própria
impressão 3D tem a e depois por cima
vocês aí sim Podem colocar a tinta que
quiserem por o primeiro já vai preparar
a secar para levar com uma tinta melhor
em cima então é sempre bom em todas as
pinturas usarem primer e vou pessoal
aqui eu tenho que te avisar mesmo vocês
não podem colocar tinta mais porque
senão vão cair aquelas pingas vai ficar
feio foi uma coisa que eu não fiz eu
coloquei muita tinta como podem ver mas
não sei porque até ficou bom até ficou
misteriosamente mas tenho atenção usei o
superei mais ou menos a 30 centímetros
não vai ficar feio já sabem o usei um
super aí mais ou menos a 30 centímetros
Ok e vai correr bem assim
e Entretanto a nossa secar já está seca
Então agora vou utilizar spray Preto
para pintar as peças secundárias como o
cano nas outras peças sei lá como é que
se chama mas enfim eu utilizei spray
preto e eu decidi não utilizar o Primer
antes porque Pablo spray preto já é bem
forte então eu decidi não colocar acho
que é um desperdício Então agora é só
esperar secar a vocês achavam que eu ia
me esquecer de virar as peças não é na
pessoal quando pintar em peças virem ao
contrário porque vai estar lá qualquer
coisa em falta 20 sempre a casa toda ok
é um conselho Antônio Ramos Dark frame 1
e bora lá pessoal a nossa de secar está
completamente seca está bonita Vejam Só
a cortar mato o primeiro entrou muito
bem o que é ótimo agora pessoal nós
vamos colocar então a cor original da
secar que é muito parecido ao do
primeiro mas é um pouco mais escuro tem
aquele efeito assim de camuflado podem
não não ver a diferença aqui em vídeo
mas na realidade vai dar muita diferença
até dá para ver aí ó tá ficar assim um
pouquinho mais escuro Essa é a cor da
secar Ok eu tentei aproximar O mais
possível a realidade então meu acho que
vai ficar incrível Vejam Só vejam Soccer
se virem sempre acesso ao contrário
pessoal só vai ficar no Zap pintada Bora
lá pessoal vocês já devem estar um
período suprimido como é que ficou
açúcar do fortnite ela neste momento
está é 90 porcento eu vou te mostrar
agora não pesam vai olha isso meu tá
bonito ou não tá bonito Olha isso não
parece que eu comprei no site qualquer
tipo sei lá fui aí vai foi a Amazon
comprei uma escada do fortnite meu tá
inclinou a terra obviamente que tem teve
mais trabalho foi a pessoa que mudou
está em 3D ele é porque está muito
semelhante a do fortnite um
oi oi
é muito bom marca mas nós não temos a
tomar essas peças todas aqui eu perdi
esses vídeos porque entretanto que eu
meio para o canal do Sol e depois
Formatei o cartão Então esquece me tinha
lá esses vídeos essa montagem
Infelizmente o perder esses vídeos Mas
de qualquer forma pessoal está aqui a
nossa secar OK ela não está assim por
cento falta ainda algumas coisas aqui
inclusive estas duas partes aqui são
mais ou menos cinza tem aquele efeito
metalizado Então é isso que eu vou fazer
aqui olha lá pessoal e como é que nós
vamos fazer o efeito metálico muito
simples eu comprei aqui uma lata com
efeito metálico evidentemente vou
utilizar aqui um paninho aí com esse
paninho eu vou raspar a tinta nas peças
pretas e isso vai dar um efeito muito
louco aquele efeito metálico como se a
secar já tivesse sido usada e tivesse
aqueles aquelas falhas que tipo de
guerra sei lá vai ter aquele efeito de
metal muito louco mesmo então acho que
vai ser um acabamento brutal
a e agora chegamos a finalização que é
só passar o verniz e bora lá pessoal
vamos ver como é que vai ficar nosso
ficar um
e já está seca eu vou mostrar em 3 2 1 1
O que é certificar do fortnite empresta
Empresta aí pessoal espero que vocês
tenham gostado Eu não contabilizei o
número de horas que eu demorei a
imprimir a pintar a secagem tudo isso
mas na boa levou tipo umas duas semanas
tranquilamente foi muito tempo mesmo eu
não quis perguntar mais este vídeo ok
isso ainda Merece muitos acabamentos
porque Como podem ver aqui o verniz
deixou assim uma cor um pouco amarelado
Ok então eu vou ter que aplicar + tinta
+ verniz a seguir ou talvez escolher
outro verniz porque eles ficam porque
amarelo tem aqui essa floração que eu
não gosto pois assim a primeira vista
pessoal está Impecável Eu adorei todas
processo Foi bem divertido Pessoal
espero que vocês também tenham gostado É
em casa já sabe o pessoal deixa muito
like aqui nesse vídeo deu muito trabalho
mesmo a fazer já sabem mas neste vídeo
para um dos vossos amigos aquele amigo
que vocês sabem que adora fortnite manda
pelo WhatsApp e vim pelo pelo dia mandei
para ele não ligou nada só mandei um
link com certeza vai gostar de ver esta
secarem
é mas é isso Pessoal espero que vocês
tenham gostado fiquem bem e até a
próxima kkkkk já posso fazer cosplay de
fortnite Olha aí qual é esse aqui mais
gorda que tem lá o
E aí